what's your view on prenups prenuptual
agreements it's not popular to quote
Kanye West but if you ain't no chump
Hollow we want prenup we want prenup I
mean that's what he had to say meaning
uh so it's AE prup is a good idea prup
is an excellent idea prenup is um a prup
is a contract between two people that
binds their respective rights and
obligations in the event of a divorce
when it comes to financial issues that's
all it is and it's a there's there's a
lot of reasons to have them and there
really aren't any reasons not to have
them other than the fact it requires an
uncomfortable
conversation so uh I mean there's a few
questions here is first do they work
legally in general yes if they are
crafted correctly which is not that hard
to do for a lawyer to do I'm saying for
a lawyer to do because with the internet
everybody thinks why would I spend
$1,000 I can just Google prenuptual
agreement and I can get one and then
it'll be that is a bad idea like it is
it is like a will like if you're going
to have a document that binds your
rights at that level it's worth like the
most expensive prenup I've ever done was
like three
grand that's ridiculous that's not a lot
of money like so there's no reason you
wouldn't do it but people still people
will still I've had clients that have
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
they did their prup downloading
something from the internet and because
of some imperfection you know it doesn't
have the right what's called
acknowledgment which is the section
where the notary signs and it has to say
that it was duly sworn before this
person on this date and if it doesn't
have that it's invalid it's not binding
so there are weird technicalities but
yeah prenups are binding as long as
there's been some minimal asset
disclosure which is easily done in a
prenup and as long as there's not a
language deficiency meaning that the
person who is reading reading it
understands English to the level that
they understand what they're signing and
if they don't that at least they've
they've acknowledged in their native
language that there is some uh
opportunity for this to be translated
for them yeah they're binding they're
they're they're they're presumptively
binding you know we live thankfully in a
culture where people are allowed to
enter into contracts about money what uh
like what what are some prenups that
you've seen that can
be um effective or what that people
converge towards in terms of what does
an agreement look like because uh you
know the popular conception is when
there's no
prenup both sides get half and that's
generally true that that both sides get
half um equitable distribution which is
what the law is called it's the law of
equitable distribution it's not called
The Law of equal distribution for a
reason because it's Equitable not equal
now equal like Equitable is presumed to
be equal but there are exceptions to
that presumption and that's where
lawyers can get into Fun Andor trouble
depending on how you view it um it's
where we make our money we make our
money arguing that the fair result will
not be just a 50-50 split and so um
there's there's the very generic
standard prenup which is easy and I you
know that's I call that Yours Mine and
Ours like if it's in your name it's
yours whether it's an asset of
reliability my name it's mine joint
names we split at 50/50 simple clean and
you go in to the marriage now knowing
what the rules are so if you get a bonus
at work and you put it in your soul
name then it's your separate property in
the event you divorce you go out and buy
a boat and she doesn't support you
buying the boat but the boat you got a
big loan on this boat you're responsible
for that loan so I like that because I
like people having some control and I
also like people having to have
discussions well why are we putting that
bonus just in your bank account why
wouldn't we put it in the joint bank
account we should have that discussion
while we're married not when we're in a
divorce lawyer's office 10 years later
because we should be able to talk about
those kinds of things so you know what's
interesting about
prenups is that that somehow people
think there's something like it takes
away from the romance of a
marriage but but I've said it before and
I'll I'll say it again all marriages end
they end in death or
divorce so having life insurance or
having a will it doesn't mean you can't
wait to die it doesn't mean you're
looking forward to death it doesn't mean
that you're you're you're you're
predicting you know your demise sometime
imminently it just means that you know
you're being realistic and honest so
when you
marry and I don't mean spiritually
marrying having a marriage ceremony I
mean legally
marrying you're making changes to your
rights and obligations under law that's
what you're doing like marriage from a
legal standpoint what we mean when we
say I got
married is a is a is a state agency it's
been created by the state like this is a
a legal status that most people who are
in it know nothing
about they they they just did the most
legally significant thing they're ever
going to do other than dying and they
have no no
idea what rights and obligations it
created in them and the first time
they're going to get an education about
it is in my office that's crazy when
they get divorced that's crazy and so
penup is an opportunity to learn
something about it at the start so first
of all it whenever someone approaches me
about prenups and and that's like four
or five times a week probably depending
on the season right before wedding
season we get a lot when when's wedding
season well it used to just be the
summer you know say they say when you
marry in Junior a bride all your life
that's from some Rogers and Hammerstein
musical um now the fall is very big too
people love fall content fall weddings
pretty you know pictures and things
content yeah fall content content for
the weddings is for the gram I had to
tell you weddings is performative man
see the problem is though it's curated
so it's here's us picking the cake it's
not here's us doing the prenup you know
how many you know how many people I've
done prenups for that I've watched on
their social media or them being
interviewed by Andy Cohen on Bravo and
saying well no we don't have a prenup
yeah you do yeah you do you do it's in
my office it's in a folder yeah know
that's beautiful but prenups are not
published any place they're not filed
with a court they're maintained by the
two people that signed it and they're
lawyers that's it so nobody has to admit
that they have a prenup but it's but
there's a yes but there's a certain
problem with that in so far is a lot of
people have prenups and we need to
normalize prenups like there's there's
no reason not to normalize prenups
there's no reason not for for for until
some famous people say yeah we have a
prenup we're crazy about each other
that's why we're getting married you
know but yeah look we're getting you
know I don't want to get a car accident
but I got a seat belt you know like you
have it just in case and uh I mean what
do you do if you're running a
company like how what what does that
have to do with a prenup you know you're
running a hundred billion dollar or
trillion dollar company Jeff B
mhm I suppose his marriage was before
Amazon yeah his was before it was
anything but like how does that work in
a prenup like well no actually it's it's
the same I mean what you're what you're
doing with a prup is you're
identifying you're identifying how
things will be classified in advance so
you're creating a set of
rules and then you both can function
under those rules during the mar
marriage so like I for a brief time I
taught a a a family law drafting class
at a law school and when we would do
separation agreements and we would do
pleadings you know it was lots of fun
when we would do prenups I would say to
the students you know what's the main
thing you need when you're doing a
prenup and they would say well you know
you need asset disclosure and i' say
well that's not the main thing and
they'd say well you need um you know
technical language they said nope main
thing you need is a crystal
ball the main thing you need is the
ability to see what's going to happen in
the future who's going to have money
who's not who's going to be successful
who isn't what people will inherit
problem is we don't have that we don't
have that so what can we do we can
create tranches we can create structures
we can create systems and then people
can live with those in mind you you
enter the game knowing the rules right
so you know if this is going to be a
submission only event you know if this
is going to be no time limit you know if
we're after a certain number of minutes
we're going into points now okay so I
can work with that rule set and I'm
going to amend my game based on that
rule set same thing same thing you're
just going to say look what's the rule
set let's agree on the rule set and then
let's conduct ourselves with the rule
set in mind let's plan with the rule set
in mind and I think that you know and by
the way and if you're going to cheat you
cheat with the rule set in mind you know
you're cheating right you know you're
trying to get around the rule
set so
prenups are when I do a consult for a
prenup the first thing I do is here's
what's going to happen legally if you
marry without a prenup here's what
happens to your rights and obligations
then what we can change with that
there's almost no limit you can you can
amend anything you want to the example I
always give is there was a case that
went up to the appell court where High
net worth guy married a very beautiful
woman and there was a provision in the
prenuptual agreement that said for every
10 pound she gave gained during the
marriage she would lose $10,000 a month
in alimony if they
divorced and there was a here's her
Baseline wait as of the time of
execution of this agreement and I
wondered if she was like a like did like
what a wrestler does like did she like
you know yeah did she like bulk up right
before and then cut when she eventually
got divorced like is she in there sauna
you know with the suit on um but but the
and and the appell at court essentially
said um I don't know why you married
this person
having had them make you sign this but
it's binding yeah but it's binding I
wish somebody would do a contract like
that like like the rent for this place
would be more expensive if if I was
fatter and cheaper if I was skinnier and
that way I would have to weigh
in like some motivation on you yeah
exactly that's that kind of prup is
motivating well what's is it I think Tim
Ferris says that about how he does like
um he said you should make Bets with
people like it's like if you gain this
much I got to give you this amount of
money you know he says that in one of
his early books and try to make it
binding somehow which is tough yeah I
think when we create incentives of that
kind you know that's why like there was
like the no nut November No Shave
November you know sober like all those
it was a competition when people make a
competition of something they gamify
something it it you know makes it
something that people are more likely to
stick with so I mean I guess a prenup be
interesting there you know the problem
is there there's also
people put in prenups what's called
Fidelity Clauses uh oh yeah yeah was
yeah Fidelity Clauses people still do
these I discourage people from doing
them the the two things that people put
in prenups that I discourage people from
putting in prenups but very often people
still put in prenups even with my cavet
is Fidelity Clauses and sunset Clauses
MH so Fidelity Clauses is um I'm waving
alimony I'm waving this and waving that
but if you cheat I get a million bucks
or I get this much alimony or get this
amount and I know the intention is to
disincentivize the person from cheating
it's a deterrent to have them cheat but
all it really does is just creates like
an interesting legal battle for lawyers
like how did you prove that they cheated
or not all right because uh what what
yeah what constitutes cheating also
right right is an emotional affair an
affair is oral sex cheating is you know
like what what is and and by the way how
do you prove it yeah like well I was in
a hotel with her but how do you prove
that I had sex with her you know like
and and it's it's very very um you're
opening a can of worms with that kind of
a thing but people sometimes still put
them in um and sunset Clauses Sunset
Clauses is if we're married X period of
time this goes away as if it never
existed why is that a bad idea the same
reason the community property law in
California is a bad idea so the
community property law is after a
certain number of years I think it's
seven every everything including your
premarital property all becomes marital
property MH and the idea of that was
supposed to be that if you've been
married that number of years like you're
in enough of a serious relationship now
that everything is one unit you're one
person what it actually does is creates
a very uncomfortable thought experiment
that people have to have at the sixe
mark because you have to now the
honeymoon's kind of over you might have
a kid or or two and you go okay wait a
minute am I so happy in this
relationship that I'm willing to take
all of my premarital assets and throw
them in the pot right now because if not
I got six months to get divorced yeah
like and that's not so like if you say
to someone like if you got married
tomorrow and then you found a company
that's worth a hundred
million and under your prenup that's
your separate property
but there's a sunset Clause that says
that your prenup goes out the window in
15 years man at year 14 and six months
you got to ask yourself some serious
questions about where's this
relationship going to be in 5 10 years
that's brilliant and that's why kids you
pay for a lawyer that's it we we get
paid to see around corners you know I
get paid to be paranoid I tell people
that all the
time
that